the fact that he hasn't talked about
paris at all it makes me suspicious
[ __ ] your trip
let's talk about paris
[Laughter]
why does he ever let us talk this long
about ourselves
that's what i'm saying martin
you went to
yo georgia to jake paul man that's all i
gotta say
back on topic yeah
let's go what's up
talk about it talk about it
[Laughter]
a metaphor no i [ __ ] the bed in my sleep
nah you're lying i swear to god in my
life we want to have the most romantic
night of our life
shout out
to my sleep
i [ __ ] the bed in my sleep i mean
[ __ ] bread and cheese oh my gosh
straight i do okay i had a super
romantic night i haven't slept i'm all
jet lagged my [ __ ] cycles all [ __ ] up
okay
this guy goes from no bread for
tartines everything like that i mean
bread cheese non-stop oh dear on the
bread and cheese something that's not
what he even shipped
in the window
we go out for the most romantic night
let me tell you the whole thing i don't
know
it's crazy i can't believe i [ __ ] the
bed okay okay so look look go go go go
go i'm so upset at myself
okay so we do the whole [ __ ] thing
she loves you dawg say what she loves
you know it was hard
before
i thought it was her i got up i saw a
little
not wake up and do nothing about it i
started walking down the stairs like why
my [ __ ] cold oh
my god
you sleep
i might have [ __ ] my bed and slept
through it for six to eight hours
[ __ ] my bed and slept through it for six
to eight hours
minimum
i'm walking down the stairs in our hotel
room okay and i felt about like the
third stair i was like
man why my [ __ ] cold and wet
and i was like what is going on here and
then i put it two and two together i was
like i just saw literally number number
two number two
i saw her period staying on the [ __ ]
bed i was like maybe that wasn't a
period stan cause it was on my side why
would it be why would she get on my side
and then i went to the bathroom i took
off my [ __ ] undies
wow
okay so now you had the most romantic
[ __ ] day it was absolutely beautiful
your boy was pulling out all the stops i
had the [ __ ] video yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i know you went yeah yeah
who there's no shots you're saying this
great vacation duff
yeah that's my idea doug did a great job
he helped me out he he was the one who
found a car spot like but i also had
laurent helping out bro hey shout out to
jerking me yeah so give up give it up to
everybody else
that's all you did that was your whole
vacation i show up i look fly and i [ __ ]
the bed i'm talking to a french uh
rental car owner while i'm in a bathrobe
in in italy i was having my trip too i'm
an ideas
looking at the eiffel tower i pulled out
all the stops i called dove i know on
the run
you see ideas i thought about the idea
you couldn't even stop your colons
can i and i'll be honest i think i
remember the farc
because i pushed hella hard yeah but i
was just so tired bro and i remember i
just yeah i pushed hella hard and i just
[ __ ] punctured through dude i
literally yeah anyway so yeah so we had
a really romantic way did you have to
wake her up yeah did you try to hide it
son i didn't know the morning i didn't
y'all didn't understand i know she
already where was she no i said on the
way down i was like damn i think i [ __ ]
the bet
i thought
no i didn't [ __ ] try to [ __ ] the bed
and then went and bought a [ __ ]
person hermes a few hours
we gotta cover this thing up
we gotta somebody needs a kelly bag we
gotta cover this thing up
wow
it's [ __ ] up
we went shopping boy we went shopping
bro
women be shopping
y'all you taking [ __ ] in the bed in
paris
you know what i mean
i don't know how to hold them bread i
haven't eaten bread in in a year and a
half
are you holding all [ __ ] no ain't no
[ __ ] no
no and i'll be honest i haven't heard i
haven't had confidence in my farts for
48 hours minimum no no i've been farting
and just laying a little bit out
just like
i'm before like it's call of duty when
you like see if someone's around the
corner like you know you're like
every time i fart it's just like super
delicate a lot of focus on the lips damn
so did you buy yourself anything like no
i didn't buy myself depends he bought
himself
brandon
i sort of really brought a diaper to nah
we went to this [ __ ] store
[Laughter]
couldn't get a goddamn appointment she
was so excited we go into the store and
i'm like i gotta do something boy like i
gotta make this [ __ ] happen so we go
in there and i'm just like yo what's
good like [ __ ] the bed yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah people say it as an expression
he's probably like oh yeah what'd you do
he's like i [ __ ] does it feel like the
expression like when people say it no no
it's actually it's
it's an understatement really
people really misuse that expression
it's much different like it's good
it's much different when it happens in
real life to you and you're sitting
there looking at your underwear as you
take the rest of your [ __ ]
oh my god
you're just lucky it was at a hotel
because if this was at your house the
whole bed is gone you gotta throw it you
gotta throw out the whole bed yeah oh
you're a piece you're our piece of [ __ ]
did you strip the sheets when the maid
came or you just let her handle it i
don't know man 100 percent right now
oh come on
i don't know if we told you
i know she wouldn't like she went
she went with that bro
there's no way she would let that happen
yeah
you